MS.
HARF: Good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the daily briefing.
I do not have anything at the top, so I will
go to your questions.
QUESTION: Can you just go through for us the
phone calls that the Secretary had yesterday
and any that he might have had today, specifically
related to Syria?
MS.
HARF: Absolutely.
Yesterday, the Secretary spoke with the UN
Secretary General Ban Ki-moon, with the Arab
League Secretary General Elaraby, with EU
High Representative Ashton, with the Egyptian
Foreign Minister Fahmy, with Turkish Foreign
Minister Davutoglu, Emirati Foreign Minister
Abdallah bin Zayid, Saudi Foreign Minister
Saud al-Faysal, NATO Secretary General Rasmussen,
Qatari Foreign Minister al-Attiyah, two calls
with Jordanian Foreign Minister Judeh, a call
with the UK Foreign Secretary Hague, and another
call -- excuse me -- with the Arab League
Secretary General.
Those were all yesterday.
QUESTION: So --
MS.
HARF: So --
QUESTION: Sorry.
Yesterday, two with Elaraby?
MS.
HARF: Correct, yes.
QUESTION: And two with --
MS.
HARF: -- with Judeh.
QUESTION: With Judeh.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: And then one each with the others
that you --
MS.
HARF: Correct, yes.
And then today, so far on my list -- and just
for planning purposes, I think for a few days
we'll send an update at the end of the day
with all of the list of calls that we're doing
on this.
But so far today, he's spoken with the Russian
Foreign Minister Lavrov and with the Moroccan
Foreign Minister as well.
QUESTION: Okay.
Could I just ask: Could you make an exception
to that end of the day grouping if he happens
to call Assad or Muallim?
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: Okay.
Thank you.
You've seen the Arab League statement from
this morning.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: I'm wondering what you have -- if
you have any reaction/response to it.
MS.
HARF: Yes.
Well, I think it was a very strong statement
that made a few points, and let me pull those
up right now.
I know you all have seen it as well: sharply
condemned the use of banned chemical weapons,
something, of course, that we agree with;
called for holding the Syrian regime fully
responsible for this crime.
And I think it would be important to say at
the top that we believe that any careful review
of the facts in this situation leads to the
conclusion that the regime was, in fact, behind
this horrific chemical weapons attack.
It's undeniable that chemical weapons were
used here on a large scale.
We know that the regime maintains custody
of those weapons and uses these types of rockets,
and we also know that the opposition does
not have those capabilities.
We'll have additional information forthcoming
from the intelligence community in the days
to come on this assessment.
QUESTION: Would you say that in the Secretary's
phone calls yesterday and the one today with
the Moroccan --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- I mean the calls yesterday particularly
to the Arab foreign ministers and to Elaraby,
that this statement or the meeting that this
statement emanated from was a subject of conversation?
MS.
HARF: I don't know if the statement was a
subject of their conversations.
QUESTION: No.
The meeting.
MS.
HARF: I don't know if the meetings specifically
-- I know the Arab League remains in emergency
session.
The Secretary in all of these calls has been
discussing clearly the assessment that we're
undertaking and how we will at some point
be making a decision about a response.
I don't have more specifics in terms of those
calls.
QUESTION: Okay.
So I'm just curious: Do you have -- I mean,
you said it was a very strong statement.
Is the Administration pleased with what the
Arab League had to say?
MS.
HARF: I think we -- both when it comes to
the Arab League, but anybody else -- would
encourage people and organizations to make
strong statements condemning the use of chemical
weapons in this case and all others.
QUESTION: Well, can I --
QUESTION: What -- I mean, just --
QUESTION: Can I jump in?
QUESTION: Let me just -- let me just --
MS.
HARF: Let me let Matt finish.
QUESTION: I just have one more on this statement
--
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- and then Elise can take over.
The statement also urged the -- called on
the Security Council to overcome its differences
-- the members of the Security Council to
overcome their differences and to take deterrent
action against this.
Is this something the United States feels
is necessary before any kind of a response
is implemented?
MS.
HARF: Well, I would underscore again today
that the President has not yet made a decision
on --
QUESTION: I'm not -- I know.
Go ahead.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
Thank you.
I would underscore that the President has
not yet made a decision yet, so I'm not going
to hypothetically talk about what may or may
not be part of that decision.
I know there are a lot of rumors out there
about whether we'll take Action A or Action
B and what that might entail.
Clearly, the Secretary and the President and
others remain in close consultation with our
international partners and allies.
We've read out a lot of those calls.
That consultation will continue.
QUESTION: I'm not asking what the response
is going to be.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: But in the range of responses that
the Administration is considering, do any
-- would any of them, in the opinion of the
Administration, require action by the UN Security
Council?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to answer that question
one way or the other before the President's
made a decision.
QUESTION: Okay.
So on this statement, did you -- was this
statement kind of formulated as a result of
you sharing?
Because they clearly hold the regime accountable
-- holding the regime fully accountable for
this horrible crime.
Was that -- were you sharing your intelligence
assessments that you said you'll share with
the public?
Have you been sharing those intelligence assessments
with the Arab League as they formulated their
statement that was very kind of undoubtedly
pointing the finger at the regime?
MS.
HARF: Well, I would say a couple points.
Broadly speaking, we are sharing our assessment
with our allies and partners around the world
as we make them.
I don't know, to be honest with you, if that
was part of what went into the Arab League
statement.
I think you'd have to check with them about
what helped them formulate their statement.
But I think it's crystal clear to anybody
looking at this that the regime was responsible
here.
QUESTION: Well, it's crystal clear circumstantially,
but it would have to -- you -- as you said,
that you would put out your intelligence assessment
that would prove what you're saying is undeniable.
So I mean, I guess we'll be waiting for that.
But my question is: Did you ask the Arab League
to issue some kind of statement that would
show that the Arabs hold the regime accountable
for that?
MS.
HARF: Well, clearly the Arab League makes
decisions about its statements --
QUESTION: I understand that.
But did you --
MS.
HARF: Can I finish?
QUESTION: Yeah, sure.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
Thank you.
Clearly, the Arab League can make decisions
about its statements on its own.
We have called publicly and privately on everybody
to strongly condemn what happened in Syria
and to make it clear that we need to hold
the regime accountable.
So I'm not going to specifically outline what
the Secretary's discussions were with the
Secretary General, other than to say that,
clearly, we call on people and organizations
around the world to make such strong statements.
QUESTION: Do you see this statement as an
endorsement of or in support of any action
that you say that you -- you say that there
will be a response.
MS.
HARF: Correct.
QUESTION: Do you see this as a call by the
Arab League for some kind of international
response?
MS.
HARF: Well, they very clearly said that they
need -- the regime needed to be held accountable,
and we've been -- said that we will respond
appropriately as the President makes a decision.
So I think that is pretty crystal clear in
their statement.
QUESTION: So --
QUESTION: So if the U.S. were to take a response,
then you see this Arab statement as a kind
of -- I don't want to say "green light," but
a --
MS.
HARF: I think you're taking it a step further.
The President hasn't made a decision yet,
and I wouldn't --
QUESTION: He hasn't made a decision on what
he's going to do, but --
MS.
HARF: Okay.
QUESTION: -- Secretary Kerry, Secretary Hagel
talking about --
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: -- they're ready to go like that,
it's pretty clear that the Administration
is kind of putting out there that there is
going to be some kind of response, whether
it's military or something else.
MS.
HARF: I'm saying there's going to be a response.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: Nobody is hiding that.
QUESTION: Okay.
So do you --
MS.
HARF: What I was going to say before you interrupted
me was that the President hasn't made a decision
yet.
I wouldn't read into this Arab League statement
a specific endorsement of a specific decision
that has not yet been made.
That's a step further.
QUESTION: Well, a decision has been made to
do something.
MS.
HARF: Correct.
But the decision about what has not yet been
made.
QUESTION: Do you see this as any kind of legal
support from the Arab League?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to do any sort of legal
analysis today about a hypothetical decision
that has yet to be made.
QUESTION: So --
MS.
HARF: Yes, Lesley.
QUESTION: Can I have one?
Was the Secretary meeting with the President
this morning?
MS.
HARF: Not to my knowledge.
I can double-check on his schedule.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: Not to my knowledge, no.
QUESTION: Then would the --
MS.
HARF: He clearly remains -- let me just say
he clearly remains in close contact with senior
officials in the White House, and if we have
any meetings to read out or the White House
has to read out, we can do so.
QUESTION: Are you --
QUESTION: What was the reason for postponing
that meeting with the Russians?
Do you feel that there is just nothing to
be said right now on the political process,
that a response is imminent or -- not your
words -- that a response is to be soon and
that that just has to be on hold for now and
that you wouldn't make any gains from a meeting
like that?
MS.
HARF: Well, given our ongoing consultations
about an appropriate response to the chemical
weapons attack, we have decided to postpone
this week's meeting that was supposed to happen
in The Hague.
We want it to happen at the time when we have
the best chance to make progress.
We are working now with the Russians to reschedule
it.
I would underscore strongly that this is only
a postponement; it is not a cancelation of
the meeting.
And I think that what happened on August 21st
only underscores the need for a political
solution, and we remain fully invested in
a comprehensive and durable political solution
to the crisis in Syria because we continue
to believe that there is no military solution
to this crisis.
QUESTION: So what kind of message would you
be sending by cutting off those, because some
people think that you feel -- you should keep
those diplomatic lines open?
And clearly there are calls, but there's nothing
better than face-to-face meetings.
MS.
HARF: Well, as I said, the Secretary spoke
with the Russian Foreign Minister today, so
his level of consultation on this issue is
quite high and sustained and will continue
to be.
We did not believe that this was the right
timing for this meeting, but again, we are
working right now with the Russians to reschedule
it at a time that makes more sense, hopefully
in the very near future.
And we'll continue working with Russia and
our international partners, again, because
we are fully invested in this process.
QUESTION: Marie?
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: On Elise's point, I mean, surely
it's very important because there is a precedent.
Back in 1990, the Arab League met and basically
did exactly the same thing, giving a green
light for what became known as Desert Storm.
So you are aware of that, are you not?
MS.
HARF: I'm aware of the history, Said.
I'm not going to get ahead of where we are
and make hypothetical legal analysis about
a decision that hasn't been made yet.
QUESTION: Right.
But surely you see this as some sort of an
endorsement.
Is it not?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to use that word, Said.
QUESTION: Okay, all right.
MS.
HARF: We think it's a strong statement, and
I'm not going to go any further.
QUESTION: But I mean --
QUESTION: On the issue -- on the issue of
crystal clear, because you keep saying crystal
clear --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- but so far, what we have seen
are videos supplied by a party to the combat,
when we have seen that you keep stating that
only the Syrian regime has the rocket capability
and so on.
So it all seems to be conjecture or it seems
to be circumstantial, not really -- not something
--
MS.
HARF: It's not circumstantial evidence that
the regime maintains custody of these kind
of weapons.
We have a broad --
QUESTION: Right.
MS.
HARF: -- array of information that points
to that, that they are the only ones that
have the capability to use these kind of rockets
and delivery systems, that the opposition
does not have those capabilities.
And I would add to that, before I get to your
next question, that we've already had a high
confidence assessment from our intelligence
community that the regime has used chemical
weapons during this conflict.
So as I said, the intelligence community will
be sharing additional information about what
underlies this assessment, but I think that
any assertion that the opposition could be
behind this just defies logic.
QUESTION: Okay.
So from your point of view, what useful purpose
are the UN investigators serving if you have
already arrived at a beyond-a-shadow-of-any-doubt
conclusion that the regime has already used
chemical weapons?
What useful purpose do they serve, and why
do they continue to be there?
MS.
HARF: Could the UN investigators serve?
QUESTION: Yes, ma'am.
Because apparently, you have already arrived
at that conclusion before they submit their
report.
MS.
HARF: Well, I'd make a couple points.
The first, as I said yesterday, was let's
keep in mind what the mandate of the UN investigation
team is.
It's not to determine culpability.
It's to determine whether chemical weapons
are used, which, again, they're -- that was
determined very, very shortly after it happened.
And that even today we saw the area the UN
investigation was supposed to go visit is
being attacked by the Syrian regime, so they've
had to postpone their investigation.
So we think it's important that the regime
not be able to use the investigation as a
stalling tactic or a charade to hide behind
under this notion that they somehow didn't
perpetrate this attack.
QUESTION: So why then -- why go through this
exercise of sending the inspectors, the UN
inspectors, if you already concluded that
there was use of chemical weapons and they
are not to determine who did what, correct?
MS.
HARF: Well, we clearly value the UN's work
-- we've said that from the beginning -- when
it comes to investigating chemical weapons
in Syria.
And it's obviously up to the UN to make their
decisions about their team and when they will
attempt to go investigate things and when
they won't.
But we've reached a point now where we believe
too much time has passed for the investigation
to be credible and that it's clear the security
situation isn't safe for the team in Syria.
So again, we don't want the regime to be able
to use the UN investigation as a stalling
tactic to hide behind.
QUESTION: So does that mean that you think
that they should leave?
MS.
HARF: Well --
QUESTION: That they shouldn't carry on with
-- I mean, do you think that what they are
doing or not doing, as the case may be, since
they seem to be stuck in their hotel, is a
stalling tactic and therefore they should
be pulled out of the country?
MS.
HARF: Well, the Secretary has been in close
contact with the Secretary General of the
UN.
I'm not going to specifically detail what
those conversations outlined.
We've made our views known publicly and privately
that we believe that the UN investigation:
(a) It's not safe for them on the ground;
and (b) that we believe too long of a time
has passed for them to be -- for it to be
credible.
QUESTION: So they --
MS.
HARF: And we've made those views known.
QUESTION: So you're not pushing for them to
go back and look at some of these areas where
the weapons are supposedly have used?
MS.
HARF: Well --
QUESTION: You don't see the point to it?
MS.
HARF: We believe that it's too late to be
credible, correct.
QUESTION: Okay.
I'm just --
MS.
HARF: But clearly, they make their own decisions
about their team and --
QUESTION: I understand.
But I mean, you don't think that it would
be helpful for them to present a report, especially
considering the fact that they're not going
to determine culpability even in the best-case
scenario?
That would not be helpful in trying to bring
about people like the Russians who -- helpful
in convincing them that this has actually
happened?
MS.
HARF: We do believe that it's too late to
be credible.
QUESTION: Okay.
And then just --
QUESTION: But to the -- I just --
MS.
HARF: I'll get to you in one second.
QUESTION: Just can I ask --
MS.
HARF: Yes, to you and then you.
QUESTION: I just want to follow up on the
Lavrov call.
MS.
HARF: And then you.
QUESTION: And then me.
QUESTION: Did the Secretary and Foreign Minister
Lavrov, do you know, did they discuss this
postponed meeting?
MS.
HARF: I don't know the answer.
QUESTION: The reason I ask is that I'm just
wondering: When were the Russians told that
you guys would not be sending anyone to The
Hague?
MS.
HARF: I don't know the answer.
I believe it was last night.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: I do not know if they discussed it today.
Let me check and see if I can share (inaudible)
on that.
QUESTION: Okay.
And then with your quibble over cancelation
versus postponement --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- this meeting was to be held on
the 28th, correct?
MS.
HARF: Correct.
It's been postponed --
QUESTION: All right.
And --
MS.
HARF: And they are working to reschedule it
for an additional date.
QUESTION: Right.
But the meeting is no longer happening on
the 28th.
Is that correct?
MS.
HARF: Correct.
QUESTION: So there is no --
MS.
HARF: We're going to do definitions now, aren't
we?
QUESTION: I just -- I just --
MS.
HARF: I'm ready for it.
QUESTION: I'm just not sure I understand what
your --
MS.
HARF: Well, there is a --
QUESTION: -- what your quibble is.
Because if there was going to be a meeting
that was scheduled on the 28th, then we can
go back to meetings, say, in other cities,
like Jericho for example, but if there was
going to be a meeting --
MS.
HARF: Just throwing one out there.
Yes.
QUESTION: If there was going to be a meeting
and then you guys decided not to have it,
if there was going to be a meeting on a certain
date and you decided not to have it --
MS.
HARF: I do think the word difference is important
here --
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: -- and let me tell you why.
QUESTION: But wait a second.
MS.
HARF: Can I tell you why?
QUESTION: The meeting that was on the 28th
--
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: -- of August --
MS.
HARF: -- is not happening.
QUESTION: -- is not happening.
MS.
HARF: It is post --
QUESTION: That --
MS.
HARF: The same meeting will be happening very
soon at a date we determine with the Russians.
QUESTION: Okay.
And did -- was that a subject of the conversation
with Foreign Minister Lavrov this morning?
MS.
HARF: I do not know.
I can attempt to find out.
I don't know.
But the reason I think it's important, and
let me underscore this, is because I think
there have been some people who have been
taking from this postponement that maybe we're
not fully invested in the Geneva process,
that we're walking away from the process with
the Russians, even though, clearly, it's a
difficult time and a difficult situation.
And nothing could actually be further from
the truth, so I want to underscore that we
are fully invested and working with the Russians
even as we disagree on a lot in Syria today.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: And I think that actually is a very
important point.
QUESTION: So you might say from this podium
that you could assure us that no meetings
had been canceled.
QUESTION: (Laughter.)
Sorry.
QUESTION: Is that correct?
(Laughter.)
MS.
HARF: Matt, I'm not even going to go there
today.
Not even going to go there.
This meeting has been postponed.
But I appreciate the effort.
That was a good one.
QUESTION: Marie, now that it has been established
--
MS.
HARF: I'll get to you next.
Go ahead, Said.
Yes.
QUESTION: -- beyond a shadow of a doubt that
chemical weapons were used, do we know what
kind -- what type of chemical weapons were
used?
Is it sarin?
Is it nerve gas?
Is it even worse than that?
MS.
HARF: I don't have --
QUESTION: What is it?
MS.
HARF: I don't have additional details about
that, Said.
Again, the intelligence community will be
sharing as many additional details as we can
in the coming days.
QUESTION: Okay.
Are we likely to hear like a statement perhaps
in the -- maybe today, maybe tomorrow -- that
-- at least some sort of an intelligence report
that is declassified or can be announced?
Is that likely to happen?
MS.
HARF: I don't have any specifics on timing.
I will say that once the intelligence community
is prepared to make its formal assessment,
we will provide a classified assessment to
the Congress, and we will make an - unclassified
details available to the public.
I can say that we will certainly be making
those findings public this week.
I don't have additional timeline beyond that.
QUESTION: But according to the American media
that the United States could hit Syria as
early as Thursday was posed by a senior official.
So do you have any comments on that?
And some analysts say, if the strike happens,
United States could take a different form
of strike from the Iraq War -- maybe drone
or (inaudible) missiles first?
MS.
HARF: Well, I'd make two points, the first
being that the President hasn't made a decision
yet on how to respond.
I would underscore that.
I would bold it and underline it and highlight
it for all of you today.
He has not made a decision yet.
I know there's a lot of rumors out there,
but let's not get ahead of where the President
is on this.
The second point I would make is that I would
like to be clear that any options that we're
considering would be a response to the CW
attack, to the CW use, that we're not contemplating
any action that would be -- for example, I
know people have asked about this in the past
-- aimed at regime change.
Nothing like that.
It's a direct response to CW use.
QUESTION: Can I ask why not, though?
I mean, your stated policy goal from President
Obama two years ago, almost to the day -- it
might even be the actual one-year -- two-year
anniversary but --
QUESTION: It is.
QUESTION: -- that President Assad should go.
MS.
HARF: Well --
QUESTION: So if you're --
MS.
HARF: We continue to believe that President
Assad has lost all legitimacy and that he
should go.
Any specific action taken in response to the
CW attack will be -- again, in response to
that attack.
We will continue helping the opposition gain
strength on the ground.
But I think we've made clear that there's
no military solution to this conflict, and
that's exactly why we remain fully invested
in the Geneva process.
QUESTION: But I mean -- in fact, I think this
was the subject of a Wall Street Journal article
or op-ed today -- I mean, don't you -- if
you want to prevent the use of chemical weapons
again, don't you just need to eliminate the
source of the chemical weapons?
MS.
HARF: Well, that's a very broad statement,
Elise.
What exactly do you mean by "the source?"
QUESTION: I mean, if you're saying that the
regime used chemical weapons and you need
to respond to these chemical weapons and you
want to prevent them from happening again,
why not just get rid of Assad in your response?
Why shouldn't the ultimate response be to
stop them from ever being used by this regime
again?
MS.
HARF: Again, the President hasn't made a decision.
He will be making one based on --
QUESTION: So it's possible that it could be
regime change then.
MS.
HARF: I just said very clearly that we are
not contemplating any action aimed at regime
change.
QUESTION: But I don't understand why not,
though.
MS.
HARF: Because we're not.
QUESTION: On the -- did you say --
QUESTION: We're not going to --
QUESTION: -- and I -- forgive me because I
--
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- did you say that it was aimed
at -- whatever the response is going to be,
it is aimed at deterring future use of chemical
weapons --
MS.
HARF: I think --
QUESTION: -- as part of the --
MS.
HARF: I think as we get closer to a response,
clearly that's one thing that people are talking
about.
Clearly, we want to deter future use of chemical
weapons use.
QUESTION: Okay.
Can I ask then --
MS.
HARF: So I wouldn't disagree with that notion.
QUESTION: Okay.
Was that also the aim of the first -- of the
response to the first time that you had documented
evidence of a chemical weapons attack?
MS.
HARF: I think when we announced our policy
change we said that we were increasing our
assistance to the opposition to help them
grow stronger on the ground in their fight
against the Assad regime.
QUESTION: So why wasn't it then, after the
Assad regime had, to your understanding, shown
itself willing and able to use chemical weapons,
why wasn't your response to the first time
something that you thought would be a deterrent
to the use -- to a second or a third or a
fourth use?
MS.
HARF: Well, I'm not saying that it wasn't,
actually.
I think that, clearly, we want to take actions
that would deter the regime from using chemical
weapons in the future.
And what we saw here was a gross escalation
of the use of chemical weapons.
QUESTION: So in other --
MS.
HARF: So I'm not saying that it wasn't part
of the decision that went in to increase the
scale and the scope of the assistance then.
QUESTION: Well, if it wasn't -- or if it was,
if you're saying -- I mean, can you say for
sure -- can you say positively whether it
was -- whether that was one of the goals of
the response the first time around?
MS.
HARF: I think that's certainly been a goal
of ours all along.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: And I would say that at about this decision
as well.
Yes.
QUESTION: So here's -- okay.
So the -- can we assume that the range of
options that the President is considering
now start above the level of increasing the
size and the scope and scale of the -- of
your support for the opposition, given the
fact that deterrence was one of your goals
the first time around, and it clearly, clearly
didn't work?
MS.
HARF: I think it's fair to say that we've
been clear that this was a mass escalation
in chemical weapons use and that we are going
to be making a decision -- the President is
-- on an appropriate response.
QUESTION: All right.
MS.
HARF: So I think that's a fair --
QUESTION: Well, would you be willing to concede
--
MS.
HARF: I think that's a fair judgment to make,
Matt.
QUESTION: Would you be willing to concede
-- would you be willing to concede that your
response to the first documented case of chemical
weapons use was not effective as a deterrent
to the Assad regime using chemical weapons
again?
MS.
HARF: Well, clearly we have now assessed that
the Assad regime did use chemical weapons
again.
QUESTION: All right.
Now, and I've just got two more and these
are very brief.
They're on the calls.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: I just want to make sure -- his
calls this morning.
Both of them -- anything other than Syria
discussed with Lavrov that you're aware of?
MS.
HARF: I don't know.
I haven't gotten a full readout of that.
I will check on that, and if we can give you
a more fulsome readout, I --
QUESTION: And the Moroccan call was about
Syria -- or Syria-centric?
MS.
HARF: Syria was discussed.
Yes.
QUESTION: Can I ask why all this talk about
a response?
Why not just take the response?
MS.
HARF: Well, at some point, the President will
be making a decision.
QUESTION: It just seems that there's --
MS.
HARF: These are very serious issues, and we
need to calibrate and discuss and --
QUESTION: Well, it doesn't --
MS.
HARF: -- debate any potential response very
carefully with the national security team.
QUESTION: Well, it doesn't sound as if you're
calibrating at all.
I mean, all we hear is that there's going
to be a response, there's going to be a response.
I mean, why do you have to keep telling us
or anybody that there's going to be a response?
Why don't you just warn the Syrians and make
your response?
MS.
HARF: Because the President hasn't made a
decision about an appropriate response yet.
We -- so just to be clear --
QUESTION: So it's okay to just talk about
some -- and you keep saying that you don't
want to talk about some hypothetical decision
that wasn't made, but you definitely do seem
to be talking about some hypothetical response
that hasn't been decided on.
MS.
HARF: I have been clear that we are going
-- the President is going to make a decision
on a response.
Let's remember this attack didn't take place
that long ago.
We've been gathering information; we have
been working, obviously with the UN at first,
to see -- with the UN investigation to see
if they would be granted access.
They weren't.
We've been gathering information in the days
since, and we've put an assessment together.
This didn't happen three months ago.
It just happened recently, and any response
is a very -- it's an important decision that
the President and the national security team
certainly don't take lightly and they don't
make quickly just to comport with what people
-- with the timeline in which people think
it should be made.
QUESTION: I'm not saying that it should be
any specific timeline, but you definitely
seem to be talking a lot about some hypothetical
response.
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: So I mean, why don't you just -- I
mean, I just don't understand why all the
-- there's just a lot of public talk about
it.
MS.
HARF: That's because you keep asking me questions
about our response.
QUESTION: No, no.
In all the --
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: -- statements that the Administration
and --
QUESTION: Let's remember we didn't ask the
Secretary to come down yesterday and make
--
MS.
HARF: I know.
And to be clear, his --
QUESTION: So --
MS.
HARF: -- a lot of his statement wasn't about
a response.
It was about the international norms that
were violated.
It was about the grotesque situation that
had happened here.
It was about the Assad regime failing to stand
by what they said and give access to the UN.
So his statement wasn't all about a response,
but it made clear that we will respond, absolutely.
QUESTION: Marie, Marie, could you explain
to us if deterrence also includes neutralizing
the capacity -- the technical capacity the
regime has to launch chemical weapons?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to get into that level
of detail about what potential outcomes might
come from this decision.
QUESTION: But you do assign the final responsibility
for launching any chemical attack with the
President of Syria Bashar al-Assad, correct?
MS.
HARF: Correct, yes.
QUESTION: Okay.
So he --
MS.
HARF: With him and with the regime.
QUESTION: He is actually an actual target,
he could be an actual target --
MS.
HARF: I did not say that.
QUESTION: -- as part of that deterrence, correct?
MS.
HARF: I did not say that.
I said that we are not contemplating any action
aimed at regime change.
QUESTION: Okay.
So you are --
MS.
HARF: So don't take those words --
QUESTION: All right.
Okay.
MS.
HARF: -- three steps down the road there.
QUESTION: I'm trying to understand --
MS.
HARF: I know.
QUESTION: -- to clarify --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- because he's -- at the end of
the day, he's the decision maker.
He's the person that is going to continue
to launch or not to launch.
So should he or should he not be a legitimate
target?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to answer that question
that way, Said.
I have said that we are not contemplating
any action that's aimed at regime change,
and I'm just not going to go any further on
that.
QUESTION: Can we --
QUESTION: Even though that's your stated policy
goal?
I mean, that's your stated policy goal.
So what you're saying is any action that you're
going to take is not in line with your stated
policy goal of Assad leaving office.
MS.
HARF: I would strongly disagree with that,
Elise.
We have been clear that our policy goal is
Assad leaving office, and that needs to happen
through a political solution, through a Geneva-like
process that we're working through right now.
QUESTION: That has --
MS.
HARF: That is our policy goal.
QUESTION: That actually no -- that I mean,
by all accounts, has absolutely made no progress
since you started this whole process.
I don't even know how long ago it was.
I mean, what progress have you made since
Secretary Kerry and Foreign Minister Lavrov
first -- since the first Geneva meeting, what
progress has been made in getting the two
sides to come together?
MS.
HARF: Well, I think a couple of points I would
point to.
Clearly, we all know this is a difficult process.
And again, this isn't going to happen just
overnight because it's the best thing for
the Syrian people.
When the Foreign Minister -- when Foreign
Minister Lavrov was here for the 2+2, he and
Secretary Kerry reaffirmed their commitment
to a Geneva-like process and said they would
continue working together on it.
We've seen a couple of other things happen
in the past months.
One is that the opposition has elected leaders.
We saw that as a key step towards determining
representation for a Geneva convention.
Obviously, we all know that representation
and attendance has been one of the outstanding
issues on Geneva.
And Wendy Sherman, Ambassador Ford, and others
have continued working with the UN and the
Russians to make progress.
Clearly, progress is going to be slow.
This is a very complicated situation, and
if it were easy, it would've been done months
ago.
But we're very committed and invested in the
process still.
QUESTION: But what about getting the two sides,
the regime and the opposition, together?
I mean, you're -- a lot of this --
MS.
HARF: Well, a lot goes -- that's a very simple
way of talking about Geneva.
A lot goes into getting to that point.
All of those little nitpicky things are being
worked through right now with us and the Russians
and the UN.
It's not just flipping a switch and saying,
"Regime, opposition, come to Geneva for a
conference."
We want to have a conference at the right
time, when we feel it can be most successful,
because that's ultimately what's in the best
interest of the Syrian people.
And we're just not there yet, but we continue
working with the Russians and the UN on it.
QUESTION: Don't you think this latest undeniable
action by the regime kind of makes the likelihood
of a -- of the opposition sitting down with
them highly improbable?
MS.
HARF: Not at all.
I think it actually underscores the importance
of the political process and why there is
no military solution here.
I think it underscores why we need to work
through a political process to end this exact
bloodshed in Syria.
QUESTION: Is there not a danger that if you
do attack, which looks like will happen, that
a political solution will be -- that there
just won't be that interest in coming to the
table, that in the end it will be a military
solution?
MS.
HARF: Well, our position has not changed that
we don't believe there's a military solution
here, that any response -- again, which I
will say, a decision has not been made on
-- is aimed at responding to the CW use.
But our position on the ultimate necessity
of a political solution has not changed here.
QUESTION: Marie, is the response -- has the
response --
MS.
HARF: I'll get to you in one second.
Finish up?
QUESTION: Is the response that the President
is considering limited to military force?
MS.
HARF: He is looking at a wide range of options.
I'm not going to further catalogue that for
you.
I think we've been clear for a year that the
President has a variety of military contingencies
on his desk, options for Syria that he can
--
QUESTION: Short of --
MS.
HARF: -- that he can take, if he chooses to
so, but I'm not going to categorize it that
way.
QUESTION: And then just one more.
Could the presence --
MS.
HARF: Just one second.
QUESTION: Could the presence of the UN team
on the ground in Damascus delay or to come
into the -- be part of the deciding factor
on when to attack?
MS.
HARF: I don't want to even venture to guess
how that might play into some sort of hypothetical
decision.
QUESTION: Can I --
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: Short of your response to the last
question, there is one option that has been
ruled out; is that correct?
MS.
HARF: Regime change.
QUESTION: No.
MS.
HARF: What did you say?
QUESTION: There is one option that has been
ruled out.
MS.
HARF: Oh, boots on the ground.
QUESTION: Yes.
MS.
HARF: Correct.
QUESTION: Right?
Okay.
So you're not --
QUESTION: And a no-fly zone?
QUESTION: So I can't read my notes, I apologize,
so I want to ask -- so I have to ask you instead.
MS.
HARF: That often happens to me, too.
I sympathize with you.
QUESTION: Did you welcome -- did you say you
welcome the Arab League decision?
Is that correct?
MS.
HARF: The statement?
QUESTION: Yeah, the statement.
I'm sorry, the statement, yes.
MS.
HARF: I -- yeah, I'm fine saying that we welcome
the statement.
QUESTION: Yes.
Okay, all right.
So if you're welcoming that, do you -- are
you at all disappointed by the responses by
the Russians and the Chinese so far, or non-responses
to this -- to -- if you say that you'd like
-- you've encouraged people to make strong
statements condemning this and attacking it.
Are you disappointed?
Do you think that, as has been said numerous
times, even in -- by the previous Secretary
of State, that they're on the wrong side of
history --
MS.
HARF: I think --
QUESTION: -- by ignoring --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- or choosing to not come out and
condemn what happened?
MS.
HARF: Well, I actually -- I would reference
what the Secretary said yesterday, that anybody
who perpetrates this notion or this falsehood
that anybody but the regime could be behind
this needs to check their conscience.
QUESTION: Right.
But I want you -- I would like him --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- but since he's not here and you
are --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- to identify who it is that is
-- that needs to check their conscience.
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to parse that further
for you.
I will --
QUESTION: No --
MS.
HARF: I'm just not going to do it, Matt.
I will say that we have -- it's been clear
who's been out there saying -- casting doubt
on the fact that the regime used these chemical
weapons.
We've also been clear that even though we
have differences of opinion with some of our
partners around the world, including the Russians,
on Syria, that we will continue talking to
them about it, which is clear from the Secretary's
call today.
QUESTION: All right.
And the last thing is that when you say that
your goal is not regime change --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- but you also say that Assad --
MS.
HARF: That we're not contemplating any action
aimed at regime change, correct, in this response.
QUESTION: Right, okay.
I want to divorce it from this -- the response
to the chemical weapons.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
QUESTION: Your goal, though, your ultimate
goal is not regime change.
Correct?
MS.
HARF: Well, we've been clear that our ultimate
-- I mean, policy goal, our ultimate position
is that Assad no longer has legitimacy --
QUESTION: Does that mean --
MS.
HARF: -- and must not be in power.
Correct.
QUESTION: Right.
But does that mean that anyone whose last
name is Assad who is in this family cannot
be in a leadership position?
Like his wife, for example, or his uncle,
or his brother.
Because --
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to make that broad statement
or generalize in that way at this point.
QUESTION: Okay.
So then it really isn't -- your goal really
isn't an end to the Assad regime necessarily,
because someone else in that family, you think,
could be --
MS.
HARF: I'm not making a comment on that one
way or the other.
I'm just not.
QUESTION: So you're not looking for the end
of the Assad family's tyranny over Syria here
--
MS.
HARF: We've been clear that the Assad regime
--
QUESTION: -- just Bashar Assad.
MS.
HARF: We have been clear that the Assad regime
-- excuse me -- can no longer be in power.
It has lost all legitimacy.
QUESTION: The Assad regime.
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to further parse it for
you than that.
I'm just not.
QUESTION: All right.
QUESTION: (Inaudible.)
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: You were speaking about the political
solution --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- and the Geneva 2 conference.
As -- I'm sure you're aware that UN Under-Secretary-General
Jeff Feltman is in Tehran.
A trip like this is not very ordinary for
a -- such a high-level UN official, especially
when he's an American, and it could not have
happened without consultation with the U.S.
Administration.
What can you tell us about the purpose behind
that trip?
MS.
HARF: Well, I actually don't have anything
for you on that.
I would refer you to the UN, as he's not a
U.S. official.
If I have any more details, I'm happy to share
them, but again, he's not there representing
the United States, and I don't know if I would
actually make the assumption that you just
made.
I just don't have the facts about his trip.
QUESTION: Can we assume that the response
will be military at least?
MS.
HARF: I would not make that assumption.
The President is reviewing a number of options
and has not made a decision yet.
QUESTION: So the Syrian Government will be
held accountable by the U.S. through a nonmilitary
response?
MS.
HARF: Again, there -- he has a range of options,
and he hasn't made a decision yet.
QUESTION: What are the options?
What are the --
MS.
HARF: There's a range of them.
We've been clear that some of those include
military contingencies.
Some don't.
I'm not going to --
QUESTION: What are the ones that don't include
military --
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to further parse it for
you.
They're on his desk and he'll make a decision
when he's ready.
QUESTION: Marie, you mentioned --
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: -- a classified briefing that would
be given to Congress.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: Do you have any more information
on who will be making that briefing?
MS.
HARF: I don't.
QUESTION: (Inaudible.)
MS.
HARF: If we have more information to share,
we can.
I just don't have any more information for
you right now.
QUESTION: And then I was -- I also wanted
to ask: I know you said you're not going to
do any legal analysis on the President's forthcoming
decision, but leaving --
MS.
HARF: But you're going to get me to try to
do it.
QUESTION: -- no, no -- just leaving that aside
and just focusing exclusively on the Assad
regime's use of chemical weapons --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- does the Administration view
that as a violation of international law?
MS.
HARF: I think we were very clear.
The Secretary used the word "international
norms."
And actually, let me take through some of
the history on that.
I think it might be helpful as we talk about
this issue, so thank you for the question.
There's clearly a long history to these international
norms that goes back many years.
And this isn't a comprehensive list, but I'll
just make a few points.
We're going back after World War I, the use
-- in which the use of chemical weapons resulted
in nearly 100,000 deaths.
The Geneva Protocol was signed in 1925 and
ratified by 137 states.
The protocol prohibited the use of chemical
weapons, quote, "in war."
In 1997, the Chemical Weapons Convention entered
into force.
This multilateral disarmament agreement provides
for the elimination of an entire category
of weapons of mass destruction under universally
applied international control and prohibits
the use of chemical weapons.
Currently, 189 nations, which represent about
98 percent of the global population, have
joined the Chemical Weapons Convention.
So just a little history on the international
norms here at work.
QUESTION: And is it --
MS.
HARF: Just one second.
QUESTION: -- correct that Syria's --
QUESTION: Can you put that out?
MS.
HARF: Just one second.
QUESTION: Is it correct that Syria is not
a signatory to that convention?
MS.
HARF: So, you're correct.
There are only five countries in the world
that have neither signed nor acceded to the
convention, but clearly that should not enable
them to escape responsibility for their actions.
There is a reason that the overwhelming majority
of the international community -- again, that
agrees on little else -- has stood against
the use of these weapons, and Syria should
not be able to flout the clearly expressed
view of the international community here.
QUESTION: Who are they?
Who are the five?
QUESTION: Can you put that list of precedents
out?
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
We'll send something to the bullpen after
the briefing.
QUESTION: Who are the five?
MS.
HARF: And there's a little more detail, too.
Who are the five --
QUESTION: Right.
Please.
Thank you.
MS.
HARF: -- that have not -- neither signed nor
acceded to the CWC: Angola, Egypt, North Korea,
South Sudan, and Syria.
Yeah.
Still on Syria?
QUESTION: Yes.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
QUESTION: Any discussion with authorities
in Athens about the possible use of U.S. bases
in Greece on any potential military strike
against Syria?
MS.
HARF: I don't have any additional details
for you about conversations about potential
options that might be part of a response.
QUESTION: Since you brought up the history,
I'm just wondering --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- if you're -- have you looked
back and found when any previous Administration
has used the use of chemical weapons as a
legal justification for military or any other
intervention?
MS.
HARF: I think that I would strongly discourage
people from comparing this situation to any
historical other situation where chemical
weapons have been discussed.
QUESTION: But you're the one that just went
back to World War I.
MS.
HARF: No, I'm talking -- I'm laying out the
historical set of international norms that
have formed.
You're trying to compare it to being used
as a justification --
QUESTION: No, I'm not.
No, no, no.
MS.
HARF: -- for another conflict.
QUESTION: I'm not trying to compare it.
I'm just asking you if you are aware of any
previous Administration relying on the use
of chemical weapons --
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: -- as justification for a military
or nonmilitary intervention.
I'm just wondering if -- you brought it -- you
opened the door to this, going back to World
War I.
MS.
HARF: I was -- two points.
I was laying out the historical international
norm against the use of chemical weapons.
Clearly, we're --
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: -- all familiar with some of the history,
including recent history on this issue.
And I'm not going to go into a further -- historical
analysis than that.
QUESTION: But then -- don't -- okay.
MS.
HARF: Where's your next --
QUESTION: If you've then -- do you --
MS.
HARF: I think it's important to lay out the
historical basis and international norms against
the use of chemical weapons.
QUESTION: Then (inaudible) see what -- what
do you consider --
QUESTION: You can't just --
QUESTION: Respectfully, you can't just throw
it out there and then say, I'm not going to
answer any more questions about it.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
So what's your next question?
Where were you going with that, Matt?
QUESTION: Well, I just wanted -- I'm asking
you a very simple question.
MS.
HARF: Yes.
The answer is yes.
Question?
QUESTION: Okay.
The answer is, yes, the --
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: -- previous administrations have
used the use of chemical weapons as the legal
justification for intervention, military or
otherwise, in the past.
They have?
MS.
HARF: I don't know about legal justification,
but I know it's been a topic of discussion
in past conflicts, yes.
QUESTION: So you --
MS.
HARF: Hold on.
QUESTION: And -- okay, wait, wait.
Can you -- which ones?
MS.
HARF: See, I'm not going to go down this rabbit
hole with you.
We are not comparing this specific case to
any other time we've concluded that a regime
may or may not, or whatever the discussion
was about chemical weapons.
QUESTION: You --
MS.
HARF: I laid out historical basis and international
norms --
QUESTION: I know.
But you're so --
MS.
HARF: -- against the use of chemical weapons.
QUESTION: Can I just --
MS.
HARF: Those are actually two different things.
And you're trying to take me down a rabbit
hole here.
QUESTION: No, I'm not.
You're assuming that I'm trying to trick you
again, and I'm not.
I'm just asking --
MS.
HARF: Again, you so frequently do, it's hard
to tell when you're not.
(Laughter.)
QUESTION: It's a very straightforward question:
Are you familiar with any case in which a
previous Administration has used this as the
rationale for intervention, military or otherwise?
MS.
HARF: Clearly, we're all familiar with a lot
of the history, Matt, yes.
QUESTION: Let me --
QUESTION: But you are?
QUESTION: Wait, wait, wait.
Do you --
QUESTION: Then I'm just asking you: When?
Because I'm not.
MS.
HARF: When we've discussed chemical weapons
in terms of military intervention in places
in the past?
QUESTION: Yeah.
Where has the U.S. intervened on the basis
of another country using chemical weapons?
I can't think of one off the top of my head.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
Then we'll move on.
QUESTION: I'm just -- but you said --
QUESTION: Do you think --
QUESTION: No.
I'm asking -- you said yes, it has happened.
So I want to know where.
MS.
HARF: I said that there have been conversations
in the past.
We all lived through the past 12 years, and
we all remember the discussions about WMD
in the past.
That's where I thought you were going with
that.
QUESTION: No, no.
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to compare it.
QUESTION: You see, that's why -- I'm not trying
to get you to compare this to Iraq or anything
else.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
QUESTION: I'm just trying to find out if you're
aware of any time that an administration --
MS.
HARF: Again, so then my previous statement
stands.
I don't want to compare this to any previous
administration, to any previous decision.
QUESTION: But you said -- but your answer
to my question was yes, it has happened.
So I just want to --
MS.
HARF: I'm not comparing it to any previous
administration or previous decision.
QUESTION: I'm not --
MS.
HARF: So I'm not going to have a discussion
of previous administration's decisions.
QUESTION: All right.
Let's -- can we continue this afterwards?
QUESTION: You said that -- you talk here about
international --
MS.
HARF: No, I just want to be clear on this.
I'm not going to compare this to any previous
administration.
QUESTION: I'm not asking for a comparison.
I'm just --
MS.
HARF: Then why did you ask about previous
administrations?
QUESTION: I'm wondering if any -- if you are
aware that any -- if any previous administration
has used the use of chemical weapons as a
--
MS.
HARF: I don't think it's relevant in this
case.
That's my answer and we're moving on.
Thank you.
QUESTION: You talk about --
MS.
HARF: Said.
Go ahead, Said.
I'll go to you next, Elise.
QUESTION: I just wanted to ask you, it seems
that you have concluded --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- early on, on Wednesday actually,
right after the attack, that the regime was
responsible for this attack.
Could you explain to us -- I know you talked
about this before -- why did then the Secretary
took -- take the initiative and talk to Muallim?
MS.
HARF: Why did he?
QUESTION: Yeah.
Why did he?
I mean, if you had already concluded that
the regime stands behind it, and the fact
that he called him to tell him that if you
had nothing to hide --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- you should have allowed people
in right away, which means that you know --
MS.
HARF: He called him right away.
Yeah.
QUESTION: Why did he call him?
Why --
MS.
HARF: He made a direct demand to the Syrian
regime that if, as they have stated, they
were not responsible for these attacks, they
should allow investigators in.
He gave them an opportunity to prove to the
world what they were saying publicly, and
they failed to take it.
QUESTION: So --
MS.
HARF: But it's important to make a direct
demand of them.
QUESTION: So in terms of just the sequence
of events, when do you -- when did you conclude
that the Syrians were behind this and they
did not allow basically to sort of destroy
evidence and so on?
MS.
HARF: Well, I think from very early on there
was --
QUESTION: Like by Saturday, by Friday?
MS.
HARF: Right.
So I'll make a few points.
The first is the intelligence community will
be sharing more details about their assessment.
But broadly speaking, there's been a preponderance
of publicly available information from the
very beginning, quite frankly, that indicated
there was a mass-scale chemical weapons attack.
We've known and assessed for a long time that
the Syrian regime had the capabilities to
do this and the opposition didn't.
So obviously, we thought it was important
to investigate, to do our own assessment.
But this is just common sense at the heart
of it, backed up by facts and assessments
and information and intelligence.
QUESTION: If you --
MS.
HARF: Elise.
QUESTION: A couple of things.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: First of all, just in response to
this just question right here --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- if you knew that the regime had
all these chemical weapons --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- and you were afraid that they
were going to use them, and they used them
before, and you warned them against crossing
a redline and they crossed it, then why -- what
actions did you take to prevent further use?
MS.
HARF: In what regard?
QUESTION: Further use from the regime from
using them again.
Some warning?
MS.
HARF: Well, (a) this was a massive escalation
in use.
We had not seen this level of use from the
regime in the past.
I think that we made clear very strongly the
last time we assessed that they had used them
in small-scale incidents that they had crossed
a redline and that we were taking action.
But again, the Syrian regime has continued
at every step to take the actions that are
most hurtful to their people, and that's why
the President is weighing an appropriate response
in this instance.
QUESTION: Now you talk about international
norms and precedent --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- for acting in (inaudible).
Do you feel that precedent on international
norms is enough, or do you feel that any response
would require a basis of international law?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to do any further hypothetical
legal analysis than I already have here before
the President's made a decision.
QUESTION: Can I just -- my question really
was: Are you aware of precedent for intervention
based on the use of chemical weapons?
That's all I was asking.
QUESTION: You asked that already.
(Laughter.)
QUESTION: That's -- I just want you to understand.
I'm not trying to compare.
MS.
HARF: I think you asked it a little differently
--
QUESTION: I am not --
MS.
HARF: -- so let me take that question and
see if I can get you a more fulsome answer.
QUESTION: That's what I was trying to get
to.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
QUESTION: I wasn't trying to go after Iraq.
MS.
HARF: I think you asked it a little differently,
which is why I responded the way I did, so
let me look into that question and see if
there's more I can share with you.
QUESTION: Because I'm not -- I'm honestly
not aware of one.
There may very well be one.
I'm just curious if you know what it is.
MS.
HARF: A specific response to a specific use
of chemical weapons.
I think the way you asked it -- and maybe
this is why I was confused -- was whether
it had been part of the case broadly speaking
for military action in the past.
QUESTION: That's also --
MS.
HARF: Those are two different questions, I
think.
I will take it and get you --
QUESTION: That's -- I think it's the same
thing, but --
MS.
HARF: They're actually two different questions,
but I will take your actual question and endeavor
to get you a more fulsome response.
QUESTION: All right.
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: Marie, to be perfectly clear, yesterday
you said the U.S. has very little doubt on
the fact that the regime is responsible for
the Wednesday attack.
Today you have absolutely no doubt that Damascus
is behind the attack last week?
MS.
HARF: Correct.
Correct.
QUESTION: Okay.
And the French President has just said that
the decision from the U.S. will be taken in
the coming days.
Is he correct?
MS.
HARF: Well, I think we've been clear that
we feel a sense of urgency here to make a
decision.
But the President hasn't made one yet.
I don't want to put any timeline on it beyond
that.
QUESTION: Change topic?
MS.
HARF: Anything else on Syria?
Yes.
QUESTION: I have one more.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
QUESTION: You said, kind of following on this,
that now we're crystal clear and the intel
community will be providing --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- additional info within the week.
My question is: What is the intelligence community
doing between Secretary Kerry's statement,
which was strong and forceful and I would
assume has the backing of the intelligence
community, what you're saying today, and this
delay it would seem for the report to come
out?
MS.
HARF: Well, I wouldn't call it a delay.
Clearly there's a process to getting classified
assessments to the Hill, there's a process
to putting together the unclassified version
that will go publicly.
I wouldn't call it a delay.
There's just a process that's ongoing.
QUESTION: So this is dotting Ts, crossing
Is, type of thing?
There's not new information coming in since
Monday?
MS.
HARF: It's -- I think there's new information
coming in all the time, which is what happens,
I think, when you do intel assessments.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: But I wouldn't read anything into the
fact that the assessment won't be coming,
except at some point this week.
I don't have more of a timeline.
QUESTION: So a postponement, not a cancelation?
QUESTION: Oh --
QUESTION: So just to be clear, the assessment
will be coming sometime or to be made public,
but the President has got the assessment already?
MS.
HARF: It's my -- yeah, that's my understanding.
I don't want to speak for him on this.
I want to make sure that that's actually 100
percent accurate, but it is my understanding,
yes.
It's my understanding that at this point we're
just preparing the classified assessment to
go to the Hill.
But I don't want to get --
QUESTION: Change topic?
QUESTION: Okay.
But he's got the assessment?
MS.
HARF: Again, I don't know exactly about the
timing, and I don't want to get ahead of this.
I'm not speaking for the IC here.
So let me double-check, and if there's more
specifics to share with you, I can.
QUESTION: And then what response would you
be seeking from the Hill?
An agreement to go to attack or what kind
of -- what are you looking for from them?
MS.
HARF: Well, the Secretary and others have
been in close consultation with the Hill as
part of this -- of the process and talking
about a potential response.
I don't have anything further for what that
consultation entails.
Clearly, we think it's important to talk to
Congress about this and to talk them through
the assessment when we provide the classified
assessment as well.
Yes.
QUESTION: And then you've stated today that,
again, that the policy goal of the United
States is to see a political transition --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- through a Geneva-like process.
Analysts and observers of this have said that
it's unlikely that Assad would come to the
table while he views himself as winning.
Wouldn't it be, for lack of a better word,
helpful if the response the U.S. takes turns
the battlefield position and would reverse
his gains that he's made recently?
MS.
HARF: Well, I think it's fair to say that
every step we've taken to assist the opposition
and help them grow in strength has been to
do just that, right?
It's to help them grow stronger, to help them
coalesce, but also to help them be able to
make more gains on the ground.
So I think that's been a broad goal from the
beginning and will continue to be, I'm sure,
with any eventual decision that the President
makes.
QUESTION: So when we're looking at the response,
you've ruled out that this action would be
aimed at regime change.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: Some have said that it could be
a specific response to chemical weapons use
and nothing further than that.
But my question is: Is there an element of
it that would be aimed at helping change the
balance of power on the ground, or do you
view responding specifically to a chemical
weapons attack as doing that as well?
MS.
HARF: I think they're probably just any action
-- any decision would probably meet both objectives.
But again, no decision has been made yet,
so we're going to keep doing things that help
the opposition grow and also respond to this.
But again, I don't want to get ahead of what
the goals of a response would be before a
decision on what that response is is actually
made.
QUESTION: Marie, are you aware that most -- in
fact, if not all -- public polls show that
the American people, by a very large majority,
oppose to any kind of intervention?
Should that factor in in any kind of decision?
MS.
HARF: I think the President's been clear that
he makes decisions about our national security
based on what's best for national security
interests of this country, and I think it's
clear here that there are core national security
interests at stake for the United States.
Clearly, the mass-scale use of chemical weapons
or a potential proliferation of these weapons
flagrantly violates an important international
norm and therefore threatens American security.
It's also worth keeping in mind that this
is taking place in a region that is already
destabilized, and it is taking place in a
country that borders an ally of the United
States in Turkey and a close friend and partner
of the United States in Jordan.
So it's important that the United States and
the international community send a strong
message, because it's in our national security
interests to do so, and that's what guides
the President's decision making on these issues.
QUESTION: Sorry.
I missed one of the countries.
Does Israel not matter at all?
MS.
HARF: Of course, Israel is our --
QUESTION: Okay.
And --
MS.
HARF: -- closest friend and ally in the region
and --
QUESTION: But they don't -- they didn't merit
a mention in the talking points?
MS.
HARF: Clearly we will continue --
QUESTION: And how about Lebanon?
MS.
HARF: -- to talk -- all of the countries.
We have been clear that Syria and spill-out
violence from Syria has been destabilizing
for the entire region, including Lebanon,
including Iraq.
I just mentioned two countries here, but I've
talked at length about the disastrous effects
that Syria is having on other countries in
the region as well.
QUESTION: And you would argue as well -- and
the President would I assume, the Administration
-- I assume everyone in the Administration
would argue that simply -- that quite apart
from any interests that your allies -- the
interests of your allies in the region and
quite apart from the threat of proliferation,
that the -- just the use and the death of
Syrian civilians on such a mass scale is also
counter to U.S. national interests.
Is that correct?
MS.
HARF: Absolutely.
QUESTION: All right.
MS.
HARF: And the continued chaos in Syria is
as well.
Absolutely.
QUESTION: Can we move on?
QUESTION: Do you have a comment on the fact
that -- I'm sorry.
QUESTION: No.
I want to move to something else.
QUESTION: Sorry, Matt.
Go ahead.
MS.
HARF: Okay.
Continue.
We'll get to --
QUESTION: No.
I just wanted to ask you if you have any comment
on the statement by the Iraqi Government that
they will not allow any kind of overflights,
be it by airplanes or fighter jets or cruise
missiles, to go over their airspace into Syria
by the Americans.
Are you aware of that?
MS.
HARF: Well, I actually haven't seen those
comments, Said, but I also don't want to -- don't
think anyone should get ahead of where the
President is and whether or not a decision
has been made and start talking about hypotheticals.
Anything else on Syria?
QUESTION: On Syria.
MS.
HARF: Yes.
Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: When did the assessment of additional
information that caused you to change your
confidence level from very little down to
crystal clear -- when did that assessment
come out?
Was it this morning or last night?
MS.
HARF: Well, I wouldn't point to a specific
assessment.
As I said, the intelligence community assessment
will be forthcoming publicly sometime this
week.
I think we've continued gathering information
and got to a point where we felt comfortable
today publicly saying that the Syrian regime
is responsible for the use of chemical weapons
in this situation.
And again, from day one, common sense would
lead anybody to believe that, but we did our
due diligence, and we're looking into it,
and more details will be coming from the intelligence
community.
QUESTION: But you can't point right now publicly
to what it was that got rid of that one scintilla
of doubt from yesterday?
MS.
HARF: Well, I think that the preponderance
of evidence --
QUESTION: Yeah, but that's --
MS.
HARF: -- and again, the details of the intelligence
assessment --
QUESTION: Right.
MS.
HARF: -- will be coming in the coming days,
but I think the fact that only one side in
this conflict has the ability to use this
--
QUESTION: But the --
MS.
HARF: -- and one doesn't --
QUESTION: Right.
MS.
HARF: -- is a huge part of that.
But yes, the specifics on the assessments
will be coming this week.
QUESTION: But the specific thing that made
the -- that got you over that last tick from
11:59 to midnight of sure positivity will
-- you're not in a position to say what it
was right now?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to further --
QUESTION: That that will be --
MS.
HARF: -- detail the assessment.
QUESTION: -- part of the assessment?
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: Okay.
Can I move on?
I don't think you'll have an answer --
QUESTION: Yeah.
We'll move on.
MS.
HARF: Just one second.
Yeah.
Go -- on Syria still?
QUESTION: No, no.
Not Syria.
MS.
HARF: Let's move on with Matt, and then we'll
get to you, Said.
QUESTION: I just wanted to go to Egypt to
see how the -- is anyone pay attention to
Egypt right now, or is everyone focused on
Syria?
And if --
MS.
HARF: Absolutely.
QUESTION: -- there are people paying attention
to Egypt, where -- what's the status of the
review, the aid review, because we had more
people on the Hill calling for a suspension?
MS.
HARF: Well, clearly everybody is still very
focused on Egypt.
I said that the Secretary spoke yesterday
with the Egyptian Foreign Minister, and quite
frankly, in a lot of these discussions, Egypt
is discussed as well.
Clearly everybody is focused on both.
I have no update for you on timing of a decision
on the review of assistance at this point.
QUESTION: Why is Egypt sort of conspicuously
absent from this discussion over the chemical
weapons use in Syria?
MS.
HARF: In what way?
QUESTION: In many ways.
I mean, they're not --
MS.
HARF: How should it be part of this discussion?
QUESTION: Are you discussing with them the
consequences of this chemical attack in Syria?
MS.
HARF: With the Egyptians?
QUESTION: Yes.
MS.
HARF: Well, the Secretary spoke with the Egyptian
Foreign Minister yesterday.
I don't have a more fulsome readout of that
call, but clearly we're talking to all of
our partners in the region about the use of
chemical weapons in Syria, also about the
situation in Egypt.
Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: So you feel that Egypt is sort of
in lockstep with you on the issue of the chemical
weapons in Syria?
MS.
HARF: That is not at all what I said.
I'm not going to categorize the Egyptian interim
government's position on the chemical weapons
use in Syria one way or the other.
That's for them to characterize.
QUESTION: Yeah.
But does -- certainly Egypt is a very major
ally, and its position would mean a lot to
you, wouldn't it?
MS.
HARF: Well, I think all of -- we take all
of our partners' positions seriously.
That's why the Secretary is engaged with them
on the phone on a regular basis.
At the same time, Said, as you know, we are
currently reviewing our entire relationship
with the Egyptian Government, including assistance,
and determining the best way to move that
relationship forward.
QUESTION: Just on that -- on his point --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: Is -- are you looking for bilateral
-- for individual Arab countries to come out
in support of a response, whatever it is,
or is the Arab League a blanket -- is that
enough for you?
MS.
HARF: Well, certainly we believe that the
Arab League is an incredibly important organization
to come out so publicly and strongly.
QUESTION: But you would --
MS.
HARF: But we also would welcome, of course,
anybody --
QUESTION: Individual countries --
MS.
HARF: Individual countries, anybody coming
out and condemning this use, and indicated
that there should be accountability in this
situation, yes.
QUESTION: Yes, please.
MS.
HARF: Yes.
QUESTION: Regarding Egypt, it looks like that
the focusing on -- I mean, I know that Matt
asked the same question, but somehow I try
to phrase it in a different way.
Maybe I could --
MS.
HARF: Give it a shot.
Let's try.
QUESTION: -- get a different answer maybe,
as long as not hypothetical.
It's like things are going on on the ground
and we are talking about here about the entire
-- entirely reviewing the relations.
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: Are you, I mean, trying to do anything
or just wait and see what's going on to happen
and accordingly we decide what we can do,
I mean, from here to there?
Because, I mean, things are going on on the
ground --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- and it's really clear that the
more decisive decisions are make by the interim
government and more people are arrested, more
media outlets are closed, and so on and so
on.
Is there anything going on from this side
or just watching and waiting until let's finish
-- it's our plateful of Syria now -- let's
finish this food and then we can find another
thing later?
MS.
HARF: Not at all.
I think that everybody is still very focused
as well on what's happening on the ground
in Egypt.
That's playing into our ongoing review.
Clearly, we're focused on Syria, too, but
nobody has stopped paying attention to what's
going on on the ground.
That's all part of what we're reviewing right
now and will feed into an eventual decision
on what our
relationship will look like going forward.
QUESTION: Yeah, but the question is I know
that one of the favorite expression in this
town is that I can walk and chew the --
MS.
HARF: I was going to say that --
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: -- but you beat me to it.
QUESTION: I mean, it's one of this State Department
lexicon, you know what they call it.
MS.
HARF: Is it?
Oh, I walked right into that one.
Go ahead, yes.
QUESTION: So I'm trying to figure out if you
are talking -- following what's going on in
Egypt, what's your -- what is your observation,
what's your criteria, what you are doing?
Because it seems that it's not exactly moving
in the same way that you were wishing or willing
or participating or expecting.
MS.
HARF: Well, I think we've been clear that
the actions that the interim government has
taken and continues to take in some cases
have forced us to reevaluate this entire relationship.
And we've made it clear when they've taken
steps that aren't moving Egypt back towards
an inclusive, sustainable democracy.
So obviously that's all playing into our assessment
and our review, and when we have announcement
to make, we will make it.
QUESTION: It's, I think -- to that point --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- is this -- are you in a process
of making a determination or completing some
review?
Or is this a dynamic, fluid situation where
it's not time to make such a determination?
MS.
HARF: We are in the process of undertaking
a review.
Clearly, at some point the President will
make a decision about our broad relationship,
but also about some of the assistance decisions
we've talked about in this room.
So that review is ongoing; we're not in wait
and see mode.
We're looking at all of that right now.
Yes.
QUESTION: I want to move on to the peace process,
but before I do I just want to remind you
that neither is Israel nor Myanmar are signatories
to the chemical weapons treaty, so please
--
MS.
HARF: I will correct -- so both Israel and
Burma have signed, but have not yet ratified
the CWC.
QUESTION: They have not ratified.
That's what I said.
MS.
HARF: I said there were five countries only
that had not signed nor acceded to it.
They have both signed it.
QUESTION: Moving on to the peace process --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- is there anything that you can
share with us about the meeting yesterday?
MS.
HARF: I don't have any updates for you on
that.
QUESTION: Can you tell us why the Palestinians
keep saying that they are boycotting, but
then lo and behold, they did attend the meeting?
MS.
HARF: I'd refer you to the Palestinians to
explain their actions.
QUESTION: Okay.
Did anyone from this building or from elsewhere
talk to the Palestinians and say that you
better go to the meetings?
MS.
HARF: I'm not going to give any more details
about our discussions with the parties in
these negotiations.
QUESTION: So not -- their threat to boycott
the meeting was not discussed by any American
official with any Palestinian officials?
MS.
HARF: Absolutely not what I said, Said.
I said I'm not going to discuss any of our
private discussions with either side as part
of this negotiation.
QUESTION: And lastly, when is the next round
expected?
Are you aware?
MS.
HARF: I don't have any announcements for you
on that.
QUESTION: This is something that the Secretary
remains focused on, though, correct?
MS.
HARF: Absolutely.
QUESTION: So Egypt, Syria, Israelis-Palestinians
-- how about the Arctic?
MS.
HARF: I think the Secretary --
QUESTION: Whales?
QUESTION: (Inaudible) with the Arctic?
MS.
HARF: The Secretary is --
QUESTION: South China Sea?
MS.
HARF: -- remains fully engaged on the plethora
of issues that come to his plate every day,
yes.
QUESTION: And focused on all of them.
MS.
HARF: Clearly, Matt, he said that Syria this
week -- he was clear yesterday --
QUESTION: Botswana?
MS.
HARF: -- that what had happened in Syria was
a serious priority and was a top priority.
QUESTION: Can I just ask you, there was a
--
MS.
HARF: He has a plethora of interests and is
able to focus on a number of things at the
same time.
QUESTION: He's an extraordinary man.
MS.
HARF: Exactly.
You took the words out of my mouth.
It's amazing.
QUESTION: There was a report yesterday or
the day before, I think -- I can't remember
when it was -- that said that the State Department
was saying now that the review -- the Keystone
review would not be done until 2014.
Is that correct?
MS.
HARF: I think we've been clear from the beginning
that we don't have a timeline.
We haven't put a timeline on when the review
will be done.
We are, as I said before, reviewing the application
in a rigorous, transparent, and efficient
manner, but we've never put a timeline on
it and I don't have one for you now.
QUESTION: Okay, but that's not entirely true.
There was a timeline put on it before.
I mean, people had talked about the EI -- I
mean, not a decision --
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- but in terms of the EI -- in
terms of the Environmental Impact Statement
and the re-do of the EIS after the route change
--
MS.
HARF: But what I'm referring to --
QUESTION: -- is the decision.
MS.
HARF: -- I think that's what the reports referred
to is the final.
QUESTION: No, no.
MS.
HARF: The final decision.
QUESTION: Well, maybe I misread it.
But I thought it was about the -- I'm not
-- I realize that the final decision -- the
President has delegated it, but will come
--
MS.
HARF: Mm-hmm.
QUESTION: -- but I'm talking about the Environmental
Impact Statement.
MS.
HARF: Yeah.
The final environmental --
QUESTION: So that --
MS.
HARF: -- again, will be released after additional
analysis in the issues identified in all of
the public comments have been incorporated.
QUESTION: Right.
MS.
HARF: That process is ongoing.
I believe there's over 1.2 million, if that
number's correct.
QUESTION: Something like that.
MS.
HARF: That takes a while.
But it's my understanding that we haven't
put a timeline on that and aren't now.
QUESTION: Do you have any idea how many of
the millions of -- or however many million
comments it is have been gone through?
I mean, do you know where in the process they
are?
Are they still going through the comments?
Have they gone through the comments and they're
incorporating them into the report now?
Or is --
MS.
HARF: Well, let me get some more details for
you on that.
I actually just don't know the answer.
QUESTION: Okay.
MS.
HARF: I know there's a team of people looking
into this right now.
I just don't know.
QUESTION: All right.
But it is not correct or it is correct that
the State Department has said that it won't
be finished until 2014?
MS.
HARF: Not to my knowledge.
Not to my knowledge.
And again, I'm not putting a timeline on it
here.
QUESTION: Okay, but a report that said that
you -- that the State Department has said
that it won't be finished until 2014 would
not be correct; is that right?
MS.
HARF: I have -- that's my understanding, yes.
I've certainly never said it.
QUESTION: All right.
Thank you.
MS.
HARF: Thank you.